okay so it's time to do something that
we haven't done a while it's one of our
most popular segments last time we did
this
we analyzed the glorious shakespearean
brilliant songwrap which was about
moisture states of genitals and it was a
very important statement for feminists
is what we learned
we learned that to criticize that song
meant that you were in some way sexist
or that you were sexually starved in
some way we learned many things
actually in the course of of analyzing
that song well now
we have another glorious piece of
culture from the great artist demi
lovato
so demi lovato has put out a song the
song is titled commander in chief
how important is this song this song is
so important
so important she these 26 year old
singer shared a screenshot on her
instagram stories
of a comment she received after
releasing the music video the comment
read and part i hope you realize this
makes people that don't have the same
political views
feel like they can't listen to you
anymore i'm personally ashamed to be a
levatic right now but no matter how hard
it is i'm not letting this song change
my feelings about you especially after
everything you've helped me with
i really hope this doesn't ruin your
career demetria lovato shared her
response
in which she stated she had a right to
her own political views celebrities
aren't just around to entertain people
for our entire lives
i mean literally you're an entertainer
so actually that's the part we care
about the most
to be honest with you just like my
plumber i mostly care about his plumbing
he has political views i mostly care
about the plumbing lovato says
i literally don't care if this ruins my
career this isn't about that
my career isn't about that as much as i
would like to be sad that i disappointed
you i'm too busy being bummed that you
expect me
a queer hispanic woman to silence my
views and beliefs in order to please
my audience this is
i mentioned bravery earlier on the show
the stunning
stunning bravery both stunning and brave
how could it be so stunning and so brave
i mean it's just
frankly sometimes you're just in awe at
the bravery and the stunningness of the
stunning bravery
and this is one of those times a
hollywood starlet
a musical star in the hollywood
firmament
put out a song about how trump is bad
the and she i mean guys she doesn't care
if it ruins her career
the risk to her career is so grave right
now i mean i cannot think of a bigger
career risk
than being in an industry where
literally everyone wishes that trump
were dead
and you saying that you don't like trump
i cannot like the career risk there
is insane i cannot wait for demi
lovato's next song
i like gay marriage that's gonna be like
oh my god the career risk in hollywood
saying that she likes gay marriage
wow how about her next her album it
should be called
racism is bad and everybody will be like
oh my god she said it
finally someone said it and the career
risk i mean my
if she says racism is bad man she's
taking her career
into her own hands amazing amazing stuff
like what wait wait hold up hold up
what if she sang a song and the song
wore the bible is wrong
i in hollywood wow the blowback the
blowback but she said something even
more controversial than any of those
things
donald trump is a mean bad orange man
who's fat orange and mean
and you are not allowed to say that in
hollywood she
i mean if you talk about somebody who's
really taken a risk somebody who's
really stepping out front willing to
take the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune in order to defend a belief
system that is deeply unpopular with her
peers it is demi lovato
in hollywood saying that donald trump is
a mean bad man
so she put out this this song it is
indeed
spectacular i mean it is somewhere i
learned by the way i
i learned so many things during that lap
debacle i learned
that people on the left don't understand
basic humor so you could do like a full
10-minute segment
a laughing 10-minute segment about how
dumb the song is and uh you can
cynically analyze
the medical conditions necessary to have
to require
a a bucket and a mop and somehow people
will take you seriously if it serves
their purposes to do so
so i feel like we should really take
this as seriously as possible
okay i'm going to try not to be
sarcastic or caustic in any way when i
analyze this song
commander in chief because i've learned
that people on the left have no sense of
humor at all
so we'll try to be deeply serious in in
our analysis of this i learned by the
way during that rap debacle i learned
that if you can not if you can kind of
rhyme words that are super obscene
but not really rhyme them but kind of
come close like in the general
neighborhood where the vowels sound
similar they're not even like the same
vowels but like kind of similar
and if you can to make a music video
with liquid
with vaginal fluid flowing out the front
door
literally flowing out the front door of
a of a home
if you do that it's just like the merry
wives of windsor by shakespeare
this is what this is what i learned i
learned that this was like a cross
between shakespeare
and beethoven that's what i learned so i
mean
our standards have been set quite high
here so we'll see if demi lovato can hit
those standards
here is demi lovato warbling commander
in chief
which i haven't i'll be honest with you
i've only seen some of the lyrics i
haven't actually listened to the song
but i can guarantee you that because
it's so stunning and so brave it is also
artistically incredible
before i even listen to it i know i know
that it is a piece of artistic
genius i know that when we write the
list of songs
that aliens 1 000 years from now will
look at when they when they try to
discern the best
of human civilization this will be up
there
it will be like beethoven's ninth
symphony it will be hamlet
and it will be demi lovato's
commander-in-chief i haven't even
listened to it yet but i know because of
the bravery because it is just so brave
so here's some bravery being super brave
courageously courageous stunning go
it's already great nothing's happened
yet but it's hard oh close-ups of people
close-ups of diverse people
were you ever taught when you were young
that that girl sounds just like demi
lovato if you mess
bound to with things oh oh i get it
she's oh she's lip-syncing it
that's been affected and presented every
story you've spawned and i'm a lucky one
wow that old white guy sounds exactly
like demi
[Music]
suffered lovato he's wearing a mega hat
too
and here's a guy who apparently is sikh
and he's also saying they all have the
same voice with flyers and praying for
rain do you get a phone pain we're not
puns and you're gay
oh everybody's getting angry and angry
honestly
if i did the things everybody is very
upset in this music video
very upset oh wow
it's a bunch of close-ups a moving
close-up of very uh very diverse people
of various weights
genders orientations colors all singing
the same song
and lip singing to let them lotto
because demi lovato is all of us
wow this is so moving i mean you can
tell whenever there's the meaningful
piano chords underneath like imagine
that's how you know people are super
into it
i will say that it is it is kind of
weird when there are these like super
masculine men singing in demi lovato's
voice it's a little weird but
loud and proud but i'm but it's
the best part of this song is that it
never exits a range of about
five notes
[Music]
six notes okay
everyone is so sad in this video but i
get it i get why everybody is sad
[Music]
by the way most diverse casting call of
all time for this video
so very exciting stuff obviously and now
we're back to original girl
okay well that was fun i hope you
enjoyed oh the camera's moving again
oh and now we we've reached the
apotheosis
among the stars demi lovato's singing
among the stars everybody else is
against a black background but demi
lovato is all of us she's like a
god-like figure
placed amongst the stars as we close in
on her face
she's also very upset demi lovato it
turns out
that she was like mr smith in the matrix
all the other figures were just
representations of mr smith
the matrix was everything all the others
were just fakes here is the real human
demi lovato
and she's uh she's
okay so this is this is just it's grand
she's wow
okay oh my god this is the it's okay i
couldn't do it i'm sorry i tried to stay
serious but uh this is self parody
so i'm gonna read you the lyrics because
i was talking over some of them and i
think they deserve to be given their
full poetic respect
here is hear the lyrics ready were you
ever taught when you were young if you
mess with things selfishly they're bound
to come undone
i'm not the only one that's been
affected and resented every story you
spun
and i'm a lucky one cause there are
people worse off that have suffered
enough
haven't they suffered enough but you
can't get enough of shutting down
systems for personal gain
fighting fires with flares and praying
for rain do you get off
on pain or not pawns in your game
commander-in-chief honestly if i did the
things you do i couldn't sleep
seriously do you even know the truth
we're in a state of crisis people are
dying while you line your pockets deep
commander-in-chief
how does it feel to still be able to
breathe
well that changes everything because
what i got there is a compelling case
that donald trump is a big meanie who
does mean things and is really mean
well mine mind blown
mind blown mind blown she explained to
cnn
we have to turn up and vote because it's
so important our voices are heard and
honestly for me whether you're a
republican or a democrat just get out
and vote no i don't believe you
i don't believe you i don't think you
want republicans voting
she said that her inspiration for the
song was this there's been so many times
i've wanted to write the president a
letter or sit down with him and ask
these questions and then i thought
i don't really actually want to do that
yeah i know because you might get an
answer
and i thought one way i could do that is
writing a song and releasing it for the
whole world to hear then he has to
answer those questions to everyone
and not just me oh ah
by the way the song was co-written with
julia michaels justin transfer and aaron
kanata this is one of the things that i
love most about our current musical
scene
is that it takes three it takes four
writers for that beethoven did all nine
of his symphonies by himself
shakespeare did all of his plays by
himself that took four writers
slow clap for the bravery and the
stunningness well done demi lovato
you've changed the world
a groundbreaking piece of culture that
put your entire career
at risk ah man wow that was
i i i there are no more words there are
no more words there's only the heartache
of knowing of knowing
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content